>> John Van Oudenaren:
Good evening and thank you
for attending our
annual awards ceremony
for the National Collegiate
Book Collecting Contest.
I'm John Van Oudenaren,
the director of the Center
for the Book in the
Library of Congress.
And I'm here to welcome you.
A word about the
Center for the Book.
The Center for the Book
was established in 1977
with the mission to promote
books, reading, libraries,
and literacy nationwide.
We do that through a network
of affiliates in every state,
the District of Columbia,
and the US Virgin Islands.
And we're also working on
an affiliate in Puerto Rico.
Hopefully we'll hear
about that soon.
The center also plays
a major role
in the library's
national book festival
and administers the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards.
The Poetry and Literature
Center,
home of the US Poet
Laureate is also part
of the Center for the Book.
The National Collegiate
Book Collecting Contest was
established in 2005 by Fine
Books and Collections Magazine
to recognize outstanding book
collecting efforts by college
and university students.
The program aims to
encourage young collectors
to become accomplished
bibliophiles.
Of course, you're going to hear
more about the latest generation
of these -- group of
these bibliophiles
and their accomplishments.
But before we can do that,
I want to acknowledge
and thank our institutional
partners.
The Antiquarian Book Seller
Association of America,
The Fellowship of American
Bibliophilic Societies,
The Grolier Club,
and the Rare Book
and Special Collections Division
of the Library of Congress.
I'd also like to say a word
of thanks to Guy Lamolinara
from the Center for the Book.
He's the doer who makes
all these events happen
in the Center for the Book.
And last but not least, I'd
like to make special
mention of the Jay I.
Kislak Foundation.
The foundation has generously
supported many activities
and exhibitions at the Library
of Congress including
this program.
Unfortunately, as
many of you may know,
Jay Kislak passed away
earlier this month.
One needs only to visit the
great hall in this building
to see the Kislak on permanent
display to witness the extent
of Mr. Kislak's generosity
and also the degree
to which he himself
was a great collector.
So please join me in
thanking the Kislak Foundation
and all our partners.
[ Applause ]
And we have back here,
Arthur Dunckleman
from the Kislak Foundation,
and I just wanted
to acknowledge Arthur.
On behalf of the Library
of Congress I congratulate
the winners
and their accomplishments
as bibliophiles.
Speaking of bibliophiles,
we will soon hear
from renowned book
collector Glen S. Miranker.
Thank you, Glen, for joining us.
I'm now supposed to turn the
program over to John Cole
as you see in your program.
John Cole was the
Director of the Center
for the Book for 39 years.
I'm not going to be in
this job for 39 years.
I just started in March
and I don't think --
I don't think I'll
make 39 years,
but John was the moving
force behind the Center
for the Book for all that time.
Unfortunately, he has been
called away and wasn't able
to make it this evening.
So, we'll skip John and go
right to Mark Dimunation,
the Chief of the Rare Books and
Special Collections Division,
who will introduce our speaker.
Mark.
>> Susan Benne: Spoiler
alert, I'm not Mark.
Oh, the mic?
Oh okay. The other mic.
Let's see, does this work?
Okay. So, spoiler
alert, I am not Mark.
I'm Susan.
And I work for the Antiquarian
Book Sellers Association
of America.
Every year we try to find a
speaker who has a collection
that has a connection to their
collection that will speak
to the winners of this contest.
And this year we
have Glen Miranker.
Glen has had a storied career
in the tech sector in addition
to being a bibliophile.
Glen has a Bachelor in
Computer Science from Yale,
as well as a Masters
and Doctorate from MIT.
He grew up in New York,
but after completing his
studies he moved to California
and held several positions
in Silicon Valley startups.
He was recruited by Steve
Jobs to join NEXT computer
in 1990 and Apple in 1996.
He was active in hardware
development and retired as --
excuse me -- was Apple's
Chief Technology Officer prior
to retiring.
Glen is a long-time bibliophile.
He has a collecting
focus on Sherlock Holmes.
He is also an expert on
cryptology and is the Director
of the National Cyrptological
Foundation.
Thank you so much
Glen for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> Glen Miranker: Just Glen.
Not very impressive for a
high-tech guy huh [laughter]?
Can't even more a microphone.
So, just want to let you
folks know, a personal note,
that when I did retire, I
retired with the idea --
I had a vague notion, god
knows I won't call it a plan,
that I would spend the balance
of my life indulging
the two things
that I really enjoyed other
than building computers.
And that was collecting,
studying, being around books --
particularly Sherlockian.
And the history of cryptography.
And I gave it a try
for about a year
and I found it completely
absorbing and satisfying
and worthwhile, so I
haven't gone back to work.
And I don't have any intent
of going back to work.
But what I would like
to say is that you know,
when collectors talk about
the thrill of the chase,
we usually mean the
pleasures of pursuit,
the satisfactions of ownership.
We mean things like
scrutinizing auction listings,
pouring over catalogue after
catalogue, visiting book stores,
antiquarian book
shops, all in the hope
of tracking a particular
volume, finding a surprise gem,
and adding it to our library.
There are lots of reasons
to collection books
and as many kinds
of collections as --
ten times as many collections as
there are people in this room.
Among my favorite examples,
is I know a collector
who collects books on kissing.
And one member of the Book Club
of California has a wonderful
collection on medical quackery.
I even know a collector who
has assembled the definitive
collection of Duncan
Hines recipes [laughter].
Collectors as opposed
to accumulators,
assemble collections of books
and ephemera that they love.
Subjects that transfix
them, topical areas
that they want to
know more about.
I collection Sherlock Holmes.
I love the stories,
the atmospherics,
being transported back
to 19th Century London.
Conan Doyle's brisk storytelling
and his dazzling deductions,
but it's not why I collect.
The reason I collect
is I have no choice.
I have a disease.
I suffer from the malady Nick
Basbanes captures perfect
in his book A Gentle Madness .
But questing and acquiring are
only part of my bibliomania.
Many books have a tale to
tell beyond what's printed
between their covers.
And tracking down the backstory
for a book is another
thrill of the chase for me.
And it's a good deal less
costly than acquiring the books.
My becoming one of the
gently mad happened in 1976
when my wife Cathy
gave me a gift.
My collection at that point
was absolutely nonexistent.
I had shown an unhealthy,
unnatural interest
in Sherlock Holmes.
I belonged to a couple of
societies where we met and ate
and drank and discussed the
cannon and other things.
But my entire Sherlock
Holmes library consisted
of the two volume complete
stories, Doubleday --
1950, whatever, Doubleday
edition.
That was it.
And as Cathy handed me this
copy of the American Case book,
I started at it and I remarked,
you mean, you don't have
to be J.P. Morgan
to collection books?
This was a new idea for me.
Well, since that moment I
found more attractive copies
than that 1976 gift.
Yet it remains one
of my favorite books.
It's not the words on the page
that interest me as a collector.
I'm after things that you
can't see at first glance.
I seek out books that
are more than books.
Books that are fascinating
and remarkable
because of a backstory.
Many books have a tale
to tell beyond that --
what's between their covers.
Tracking down the backstory for
my books is the principle thrill
of the chase for me, and
it's a good deal less
than acquiring them.
Each book in a different way
is a portal into times past.
An interest for conjuring
up glimpse of the thoughts,
the sensibilities,
emaciations, even the crimes
of previous owners or readers.
A book can be a variable
time capsule of the year
and the place it was written,
published and distributed.
The discovery of the
back stories for these
and other books in my
library is a work in progress.
Certainly, a quest without end.
just the way I like it.
Let me show just a
couple of examples.
I think my compulsion will
start to make sense to you.
Let's consider the second
Sherlock Holmes story The Sign
of Four .
If we overlook the
printing errors,
the text in the seven-dollar
Penguin
or the free eBook edition,
it's no different than the text
in the story's first appearance
in Lippincott's Magazine .
But the backstories are
what make the editions
of the The Sign of Four ,
particularly fascinating.
First is the story about how
it even came to be written.
Any of you familiar
with it by any chance?
Besides Mike [laughter].
Lippincott's Magazine had
decided in 1890 that they wanted
to -- that they needed
to expand their business,
and so decided they
were going to off --
going to start offering
an English version of --
British version of
their publication.
And they were also looking
for new fresh authors.
And so, they decided to send
an agent, Mr. J.M. Stoddard
to Great Britain to seek
out some new young authors
and commission some new work.
And so, Mr. Stoddard took two
young authors out to dinner.
This was the summer of 1890.
One of those authors
was Author Conan Doyle.
They struck a deal and some
six, seven weeks later,
Author Conan Doyle
delivered the manuscript
for For the Sign
of Dorian Gray .
The second author
also struck a deal
with Mr. Stoddard
at that dinner.
A fellow named Oscar Wilde.
And a year later he
delivered the manuscript
for The Picture
of Dorian Gray .
Conan Doyle's story was only
a modest success in the UK.
It sold fewer than 1000
copies in its first year.
But it was wildly popular
in the United States thanks
to its illegal publication
by a myriad
of American pirate publishers.
These sales were very brisk
and although they brought
ACD no income in the US,
it did cement his popularity.
This is a fascinating area
in US publication history,
endlessly fascinating to me.
Opacious, brazen,
unregulated, phenomenal profits
for some pirateers,
and bankruptcies
for most of them though.
The backstory of pirate
publishing is well represented
in my collection.
I have more than 1200 distinct
pirated editions from more
than 45 different
American publishers.
Of the word --
of the Sherlockian works
of Arthur Conan Doyle.
The first authorized
American edition
of The Sign did not
appear until two years
after its magazine
publication in Lippincott's .
But in the meantime, the
pirates were churning out books;
paperback, hardcover books.
In fact, the champion of them
all was an expat Canadian
by birth named John Lovell.
He was by far the
biggest in terms of number
of volumes actually
shoved out into the public.
Now, this was certainly
not his motivation,
but these pirateers actually
did a great public service.
They made literature
widely affordable.
Before the pirateers, a book
cost five, six, seven dollars,
which at the time
would be equivalent
to 100 glasses of beer.
So, it was a lot of money.
And they were churning out these
books at a quarter, a dime.
If you subscribed to
a whole bunch of them,
even as inexpensive as a nickel.
In 1895 I believe it was, John
Lovell published nearly half
of the hard-bound books in
the United States of America.
His nickname by the way,
was Book a Day Lovell.
By his competitors.
There's a particular book
I'd like to share with you.
This copy of The Sign
of Four was pirated
by The United States
Book Company.
This was one of Book a
Day Lovell's imprints.
You can see that it's warmly
inscribed by Conan Doyle.
Yet I promise you, Conan Doyle
with authors like Mark Twain,
Rudyard Kipling, and other
contemporaries despised the
American Pirateers.
So, why did Conan
Doyle sign the pirate?
Where? When?
Whose book was it?
This signature, surprising
and inappropriate
as finding a pickled
caslet in your cornflakes.
This is the second backstory
around The Sign I
would like to talk about.
I've only been able to locate
about six pirated books
that Conan Doyle inscribed.
Curiously, they were all signed
when Conan Doyle was in Chicago.
He made a grand tour of
American in late-1894.
They're all United States
Book Company Publications.
This particular edition -- this
particular book is inscribed
to one Harlow N. Higinbotham.
Now, who the heck is
Harlow N. Higinbotham?
Well, it turns out, he was
a very important figure
in Chicago.
He was a leading businessman,
civic leader, philanthropist.
He was a senior partner in the
Marshall Field department store.
He was the founder
of the Field Museum.
And he was President of the
World's Columbian Exposition.
The World Fair that was
held in Chicago in 1893.
This fair by the way,
brought us words like midway,
and also brought
us an attraction
which we now call
the Ferris wheel.
So, how did the Higinbotham's
and Conan Doyle Meet?
Well, here's the story I
pieced together with help
from Frederick Kiddel's
monograph,
Arthur Conan Doyle
Visits Chicago .
And from contemporary Chicago
newspapers that I found
in the Newbury Library, where
Fred's collection now resides.
And I have to credit the
enthusiastic help of librarians
and curators Autumn
Naylor, Katie McMann,
and Jenny Swartzburg, without
which I'm not sure I would have
managed to do the
research on this book.
Conan Doyle first toured
America in 1894 and he stopped
in Chicago three times between
October 2nd and December 8th.
His name by the way,
was incorrectly reported
in Chicago newspapers as Arthur
Canon Doyle, as a consequence
of which people started
referring to him
with the honorific reverend
for the balance of his trip.
His first official undertaking
in the Windy City was a talk
on October 12th for Chicago --
at Chicago 20th Century Club
entitled, Facts and Fiction
About Great English Novelists.
The club met in a little bijou
theater on the third floor
of Higinbotham's
Michigan Avenue mansion.
It was there that the
author inscribed three books
for Higinbotham;
Study in Scarlet ,
The Sign of Four ,
and Micha Clarke .
All pirated editions.
New York bookseller James
Cummins who was the source
of my inscribed copy
sold the three in 1991.
Cummins got the books from
an elderly Chicago elector
who had relocated to New York
some years before and asked
that his identity be
kept confidential.
So there the trail
of provenance ends.
The two gentlemen were
again together at dinner
in Conan Doyle's honor
after Conan Doyle's lecture.
I surmise that Higinbotham
purchased the books especially
for the occasion.
Why? When we take a close look
at the ownership signature,
we find it's dated October
12, 1894, the very day
of Conan Doyle's lecture.
So, conjecture, Higinbotham
ran out,
quick got a couple Conan Doyle
books and brought them back home
to get them signature -- signed.
Now we're left with
a problem though.
How do we know that the
ownership signature is correct?
Well, Higinbotham
was the president
of the 1893 Chicago World's Fair
and as the president
he had his signature
on every admission ticket.
And a search on eBay
readily turned one up.
So, I had the admission
ticket to compare to the book.
As we discussed earlier, the
novel of study which sold
for a mere 50 pounds,
and The Sign of Four ,
which is only a modest
success in the UK,
the stories that changed Conan
Doyle's fortunes were the
Sherlock Holmes short stories.
The first dozen appeared
in the Strand Magazine
, 1891 to 1892.
And they were collected
into a book in late-1892,
The Adventures of
Sherlock Holmes .
Let's have a look
at a particularly interesting
copy of the adventures.
The first edition
of the adventures sold some
10,000 copies in its first year.
And the success also
ignited the sales
of Conan Doyle's earlier titles.
For example, within one
week of the appearance
of the adventures, 3000
copies of The Sign
of Four were sold in the UK.
That's three times as many
copies as the entire run
of the first edition
just two years earlier.
If we open this book,
we see that this copy has
been inscribed by the author.
With Arthur Conan
Doyle's kindest regards.
What's particularly fascinating
is the date of the inscription.
October 6th is the -- is eight
days before the book's official
publication date.
So, likely this volume
is what you
and I would call an
author's sample copy.
As an author sample
copy presented
to some relative of friend.
I have other copies
of the adventures
with interesting
backstories, but there's one
that I give the prize for
being the most dramatic.
Because of its bibliographic
importance,
and because of the human
drama that surrounds the man
who owned it just before me.
This is the third backstory
I'd like to explore.
I'm rushing because I have not
been given the usual three hours
for my presentation [laughter].
What you see here is
the only known copy
of the true first edition,
first state of the
adventures in a dust jacket.
Since Sherlock Holmes
first inspired the birth
of Sherlockians and we students
of Sherlock, and Watson,
and the cannons call ourselves,
it's been unclear whether
this edition was issued
with a dust jacket.
Sherlockian's, collectors,
book sellers have searched
and debated the question
for decades and decades.
But when this book finally came
to light in the Spring of 1984,
the dust jackets
existence was indisputable.
This bibliographic
discovery emerged as part
of another story; the story
of a man named Mark Hoffman.
He was the owner before me.
I hear from the chuckles
that some
of you are familiar
with Mark Hoffman.
Mark Hoffman again, shortage
of time, was the Mormon Forger.
He was -- he would -- oh got
ahead of myself, so sorry.
Yes, the FBI called him the best
forger that's ever been caught.
He forged all kinds
of materials.
And I won't go through
the list, it's staggering.
The Daniel Boone letters, Emily
Dickinson poems, et cetera,
which all passed extremely
detailed expert examination.
But his most steady customer,
his most easy mark
was the Mormon church.
He would miraculously
produce letters, documents,
bibles with handwritten family
records on the end paper,
[inaudible] paper,
with great regularity
and of course the Mormon
church was very eager to gather
up any materials
related to their history.
But he was even cleverer
than that.
He would always put one little
fact in it that was embarrassing
to the church orthodoxy
[laughter].
So, he was absolutely certain
that the church would buy it
and send it into the basement
where nobody could see it.
Well, things caught up with him.
He had accepted a very large
advance from the Mormon church
in order to find this
rumored very large cache
of early Mormon letters.
As the months went by and he
did not come up with the goods,
finally the church
ran out of patience
and asked for their money back.
Now, nobody knows for sure,
but the speculation is in order
to take the eyes off of himself,
Mark Hoffman decided
what he should do is blow
up a few people.
And he built a couple of bombs
and two people were
actually killed.
And he had a third bomb,
we don't know for sure
who it was intended, but he
evidently had an accident
and he blew himself up.
Not fatally, grievously injured.
At any rate, to jump
to the punch line,
this is his new home.
It's the -- he was
recently moved
to this Draper, Utah
penitentiary.
Slightly less austere
than his original home
which was the Orem
state pen Given
that he defrauded
the Mormon church,
that he murdered a
couple of devout Mormons,
and he's in Utah State Penn,
I don't think he's going
to get out on parole.
And to make reparations, Hoffman
who had his own book collection,
it was sold off and
the proceeds were used
to reimburse the Mormon church.
I was fortunate enough
to acquire what's known
as "the blue book".
But, you know, my time is up.
So, as you might suspect, I am
happy to talk further about any
of these stories and of course
answer any other questions you
might have about my
collection, collecting,
or any of the other bizarre
books that are in it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Six minutes under my allocation.
Six seconds under my allocation.
Any questions?
Yes, ma'am?
>> Tell us [inaudible].
>> Glen Miranker: Oh,
that's the blue book.
>> Oh, it's the one
that you showed?
>> Glen Miranker: Yes,
because of the jacket.
>> Is the jacket a forgery?
>> Glen Miranker:
Great question.
We've looked very,
very carefully
and as best we can tell no.
But -- and it seems -- it seems
unlikely he would have a forgery
in his own collection.
But it's possible.
The book actually has been --
I have traced its provenance.
It actually -- somewhat
back in time.
It actually -- which is
not say this isn't a copy
of the real thing.
But the book first turned up
in a bookstore in Chicago.
The book dealer is long gone.
It may be familiar by name to
some of you, Larry Kinetka.
And, but he never spilled the
beans about where he got it.
And I've even been in touch with
a couple of folks that worked
in the bookstore at the
time in the early 70s,
and neither of them has any
recollection of the book.
>> Did you put a dust jacket
protector on that book?
>> Glen Miranker: No.
I am -- I'm sorry?
>> How do you feel about it?
>> Glen Miranker: Oh, I
have dust jacket protectors
on almost all my books, but
that dust jacket is so tender.
It's in a nice clamshell --
no, no, it's in a
clamshell and all by itself.
I don't have the courage to put
it into a dust jacket protector.
Well, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Dimunation: Can
I close your computer?
>> Glen Miranker:
Oh yes, actually --
>> Mark Dimunation:
Thanks very much.
Hi everyone, I'm
Mark Dimunation.
I'm Chief of Rare Books.
For those of you who weren't in
the division, we just had a bit
of a frolic over in Rare Book
and Special Collections division
where we were looking at
collections that had been given
to the Library of Congress
by previous collectors.
I like to frame it that way,
because there's always a --
what is it picking up?
My phone? It's picking up --
[ Multiple Speakers ]
My personality [laughter].
Okay. So, we're going to
flip the order of the awards.
Mostly because Samuel said he
really liked a lot of drama
and really wanted to
wait till the very end.
Where are you Samuel?
There you are.
So, to appease the
first prize winner,
we're going to have
him come up last.
Which means we're going to
start off with our essayist.
If you'd like to come up.
It's picking up something.
You're going to -- I'm
going to talk about you.
Don't be so -- I'm
not going to hurt you.
There good.
>> Ena Selimovic: Maybe
I could read with you.
>> Mark Dimunation: You wrote
it though, so it [laughter] --
I just want to talk a
little bit about the nature
of the competition this year,
which was really interesting.
We seem to have struck a moment
in a generation of collectors
in which book collections
have become very personal
to their experience.
Every single one of the
award winners today collect
collections that in some
very direct way, speak either
to their ancestry
or their identity,
their current identity.
Whether it be relatives from
Sicily, whether it be growing
up as a hyphenated American,
or something in between.
Each of these collections has
a very personal connection,
and as a result, when Ena's
essay came up we thought
that it really reflected
directly the experience of many
of the collectors
and as a result,
we don't always give
essay prizes,
so congratulations on that.
I want to give you just a
taste of it and then I'm going
to ask her really extremely
difficult questions.
her essay goes into a bit
of a discussion of what it's
like to live in a culture
in which you don't initially
have a fluency and how you go
about obtaining that fluency.
Whether it be through language
or ultimately through
literature.
And there's a paragraph
that I was really struck
by in this essay, and
I'm just going to read it
and then the rest is your show.
I hope I do justice to it.
I discover hospitality
in migrant exile
and war literatures.
Especially the tragic
comic in each.
The convergence of these
literary traditions
and the many languages in which
they materialize reflect not
only my own experience of the
divided self, but also my life
within a pluralist
conception of home.
In my collection are books
that showcase how contemporary
US literatures travel beyond two
nation states and among
many nodes of a network,
the multiple vibrations
within a single text.
It's a lovely essay
that introduces a collection
that's very personal.
Come up to the mic.
So, I would like you just to, if
you would, give us a little bit
of a description of what
your collection entails
and what your essay covers so
they can share that experience.
>> Ena Selimovic: So, it
started out as a collection
about colonialism of Africa
and Caribbean, and then now
because of my dissertation
project I'm trying
to re-evaluate what
colonialism means globally.
So, I'm looking at
different forms of colonialism
on a global scale,
being sensitive
to historicizing them in depth.
So now I'm looking
at the Balkans
through a post-colonial lens by
involving the Ottoman Empire,
the Austrian-Hungarian
Empire and these empires
that don't usually get
talked about when we talk
about post-colonialism.
So, that's the new obsession.
>> Mark Dimunation: Yes, and
the essay will give you --
>> Ena Selimovic: And Kafka.
Always Kafka.
>> Mark Dimunation: The
essay will give you a taste
of the fact that this comes
from among other things a very
personal experience of growing
up in a situation
in which languages
and identity have fluidity
and meaning at the same time.
And is a really profound
I think coverage
of the collecting impulse
that we've seen throughout
the program today.
So, could you please have a
round of applause for her?
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much.
Third place.
Hanaa. Fire from the eyes.
Fire from the heart.
My life as a Syrian-American
Muslim.
As I mentioned --
congratulations.
>> Hanaa J. Masalmeh: Thank you.
>> Mark Dimunation:
As I mentioned,
each of the collections that
won awards were tried directly
to the experience of
an individual collector
and speaking out of a
certain kind of identity.
In many cases, trying to
reconcile that identity
with citizenship
in America as well.
And as a hyphenated American
myself, I had a great deal
of sympathy which much of
the time was being expressed.
Hanaa's essay introduces a
collection that's very personal
in terms of her ongoing
experience
with the literature
of her childhood.
And it tells the story of
growing up in Portland,
but being taken back to Syria
I guess as a way of saying it,
first under objection and then
ultimately under an effort
to make sure that she was
both fluent and literate.
So, the collection includes
stages of her life and books
that have meaning
in each of those.
So, fairy tales that were
translated by her mother
into Arabic so she would have
Arabic text to read as a child.
Then going on to books that
were collected while in Syria,
then coming back and reading
more classical poetry in Arabic,
and on to I would almost say a
kind of comic sense of identity
that appears throughout.
I just wanted to share
one aspect of this,
which I related to entirely.
And it comes out early
on in which she says,
growing up in Portland she
was surrounded in essence
by those things that you would
expect to find in Portland.
And that there was some fear
that she would drift away
from her Syrian heritage.
If you just replace Syrian
for Ukrainian you would
know my upbringing.
At the same time,
I was embarrassed
by my Syrian heritage.
I would watch Disney Channel
and wish for a grandmother
that would wear pastel cardigans
and bake chocolate chip cookies.
Instead, I got a grandmother
who made couscous while telling
stories of the Six Days War.
I wonder Hanaa if you can give
us a bit of an understanding
of what's in the collection
and how you ultimately
accumulated some
of these materials.
There's some great stories
in these collections.
>> Hanaa J. Masalmeh: Amazing.
>> Mark Dimunation: I'm going
to -- not out of rudeness,
I have to sit every
once in a while.
I will pay attention, but
I give you the podium.
>> Hanaa J. Masalmeh: Thank you.
Thank you so much for
having me here Mark.
Thank you to the Antiquarian
Book Sellers Association.
I really love the process of
putting this collection together
and putting this essay together.
And it's funny, the first
thing that came to my mind
when I was writing
this essay is the fact
that my parents despite
being Muslim,
worshiped the Holy Trinity;
doctor, lawyer, engineer.
And I think so much of the
immigrant narrative gets caught
up in that sense
of working hard,
becoming successful,
in a new country.
But I really wanted to
illuminate the common aspects
of it to give this really
colorful, three-dimensional idea
of what that heritage looks
like beyond what you might see
on the 6 o'clock news
or in history textbooks,
or often times in
library collections
that are really representative
of the Middle East and also
of the Arab-American experience.
And so, as Mark mentioned,
my collection starts off
with these picture books that my
mom would bring back from Syria
as well as these Arabic
textbooks that she'd use
to teach me and my
siblings Arabic
when we were in the
United States.
You know, I was born
and raised here,
but my mom was insistent
that, you know,
we would learn how
to speak Arabic.
And we did.
But, you know, I
did by, you know,
the skin of my teeth kicking and
screaming because I didn't see
that value in that heritage.
And I think that, you
know, because my mom,
because my dad made
such an effort
to keep bringing these
books back for me,
eventually I caught that bug.
I became one of the gently mad.
And I started collecting
books on my own.
And of course, the
irony is that by
that time my family could
no longer go back to Syria
because of the civil
war going on there.
So, it really became a test of
my commitment to my identity,
but also a test to my creativity
in finding these materials
and selecting these materials.
And this is a period
in my collection
where I actually start to go
a little bit more bilingual.
Because I'm sharing these
books with my friends.
I want them to see what
my heritage is as well.
And so, this collection
is really a reflection
of that inner process of coming
to terms with my identity
and eventually learning
to value it.
And I am so honored
to be here today.
And I'm also, you know, so happy
that there are also these
incredible young book collectors
around me whose stories are
fascinating and incredible.
And just really speak
to, you know,
how personal experiences can
be so well embodied in books.
Which even though
they're not alive,
really come to have
a life of their own.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Dimunation: So, this
of course is a collegiate
book collecting competition,
so Ena comes from Washington
University St. Louis,
and Hanaa comes from
Harvard University.
We're going to turn our
attention to the middle
of the country only by
adopting a university.
He has locations elsewhere.
But we're turning to KU, not UK.
Kansas University.
Paul Schwennesen.
I told him I'd been practicing
German all day and then I find
out it's Americanized
like everything else --
came in as a second award
winner for his book collection
which was entitled Borderlands:
A Manifesto on Overlap.
You want to come up?
And give him a round
of applause please.
[ Applause ]
This is a different
kind of identity
that Paul is searching of.
In this case, he's rooted
in the land, but he's trying
to understand about the
generations of family
that preceded him and those
that came before him have
in connection to the land.
So, it's a book collection
that documents the borderlands.
A family cattle ranch along
the region of Arizona,
New Mexico, and Mexico.
Correct? Which are
divided as Paul refers
to by artificial lines.
And then goes on to build a
book collection that documents
in essence, the various layers
of populations and impacts
on this land starting
with Aztecs all the way
up to the lost Estadon
who wanders from Florida
to Mexico in late-16th Century.
Has materials about the
first domestic livestock
that are brought
onto this vast land.
And ultimately goes
into exploration
around indigenous backgrounds
of Spanish Colonialism,
current conservation
issues, and others.
It's an impressive
and broad collection.
I wonder if you could
talk a little bit
about the impetuous behind
it for you personally.
>> Paul T. Schwennesen: Sure.
I should know better than to try
to bring out a literary aphorism
in front of a group
of bibliophiles.
But Samuel Johnson once said
something to the effect of,
"nothing so concentrates the
mind as the certain knowledge
that one will be
hanged in a fortnight."
And there's a little bit
of that here too that --
slightly less dramatically,
but it's hard
to quite understand your
homeland, where you're really
from until you leave it.
We've probably all experienced
that to one degree or another.
And this is certainly
my personal case.
I came to the University
of Kansas
through some complicated
personal machinations
that led me there and
this book collection --
I supposed I shouldn't
reveal this,
but this book collection was
not actually a collection
in the traditional sense.
I only realized that
I had a collection
by putting together this essay.
I realized that I
had been collecting
in a non-linear fashion.
That this collection
was sort of building
in the background, right.
So, this wasn't a laser
focused ambition of mine
to generate a collection
that spans the borderlands
of the American southwest.
But it runs out in sort of after
thought that it actually was.
That there was a surreptitious
subliminal act going on here
of this book collecting.
And it was a joy to realize what
I had and what it meant to me.
And what my home meant to me.
And that it only
meant that much to me
by being separated from it.
So, I appreciate the
opportunity to sort of reveal
to the wider reading audience
and it's been an absolute joy.
And thank you for
making this happen.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Dimunation: And now
for our first-place winner,
Samuel Vincent Lemley of
the University of Virginia.
Congratulations.
Let's give him a hand.
[ Applause ]
Whose essay and collection is
surrounded around the concept
of collecting Sicilian printing,
Biblioteca Genealogica:
Sicilian Printing, 1704-1893.
In this Sam -- is
it Sam or Samuel?
>> Samuel Vincent Lemley: Sam.
>> Mark Dimunation: Sam.
Sam discusses a bit
of the impetuous behind this
collection, which in fact is
to represent his
heritage, all the members
of his historical genealogy
by a book that's published
in Sicily in their year.
Which is a rather unique
approach to a book collection,
but it's fascinating in what
he manages to pull together.
So, over the span of
time from 1704 to 1893,
1704 being the earliest
family that can be traced,
he began the process of tracking
down publications
printed in Sicily.
And he has a gathering
that covers everything
from devotional literature
to constitutional history,
from the study of
astronomy all the way
up to the study of
river mollusks.
I think that's my favorite.
And discovers many things
about local printing.
Sicily in fact, being very
much a region of local printing
in which materials really
aren't intended to go
out into the larger world.
And as a result, have
a very kind of local
and in some ways
ephemeral feeling to them.
But I just want to read
a little from his essay
and then we'll let him
chatter even longer than me.
In assembling this
collection I've sought
to represent my ancestral past
by gathering material products
of my ancient culture.
Invariably, book bear traces
of their human makers,
sometimes literally but
always figuratively.
Books are hieroglyphs of
an absent human presence.
Evidence that cultures far
off or forgotten wrote, read,
thumbed, and discarded
books and we do.
In this vein, I have sought
to follow G. Thomas
Tinsels primary rationale
for collecting, albeit in a
narrower genealogical sense.
Each title listed here tells
something about a human being
who lived in a particular
time and place.
In this case, the human beings
happen to be my forbearers.
So, I wonder if you
could tell us Sam,
a little bit about this process.
It's a very interesting
gathering.
It's a great catalogue
put together.
If you could talk a little bit
about your experience of hunting
down Sicily if you would.
>> Samuel Vincent Lemley: Yeah.
So, I should say that my
collection was inspired a
continuous to be guided
by grandfather's genealogical
research he's been working
on for decades, and
actually just published
in book form three years back.
So that's -- that sort
of underwrites everything
that I've managed to do.
In terms of gathering
and collection,
most of it actually I bought
from Italian dealers online.
A lot of the materials
are still in Sicily.
As you'd imagined, the
Sicilian books aren't typically
as collectable, and desirable.
Because of that, I've
been able to acquire a lot
of things fair inexpensively,
which is great.
Yeah, I think just
the idea being
that the motivation behind
the collection being this sort
of desire to find
a material link
with my ancestral past
that, you know, is my own.
Is, you know, innately mine,
but also inaccessible in a way.
So, trying to find some link
to my ancestors, my family.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Dimunation:
Congratulations
to all our award winners
and thank you very
much to our sponsors.
Those of us who live in the
world of books in any variety
of profession, whether it
be curator, book dealer
or collector, understand
the sentimental nature
of this for all of us.
The fact that book collecting
can speak to another generation
with passion and personality
is very reassuring.
So, thank you all very
much for the evening.
[ Applause ]